trois rivières montréal l'ontario vont
être plus proche que jamais économie de
temps voici le principal avantage du
projet de train à grande fréquence en
toronto et québec selon le gouvernement
fédéral
le tracé préliminaire qui prévoit
plusieurs arrêts permettrait de réduire
de 30 minutes le trajet entre québec et
montréal est de 90 minutes celui entre
ottawa et toronto
avec un coût pouvant aller jusqu'à 12
milliards de dollars
cet expert crois qu'on devrait plutôt
investir dans un tgv beaucoup plus
rapide
là vous avez à choisir soit vous
dépasser 12 milliards dans un train week
c'est qui va apporter une certaine
évolution où vous investissez 20 à 22
milliards dans un train qui voit
apparaître comme aurait voulu une
révolution et qui va changer le
comportement
je pense que c'est bien qu'on ait plus
de fréquences pour les trains plus de
choix que seulement très tôt le matin
une fois le québec toronto je sais pas
si c'est une bonne douche je sais pas si
beaucoup de gens qu'ils prennent c'est
peut-être de penser youtube avec une
propulsion électrique le tgv aussi
l'avantagé d'être plus écologique de
pouvoir concurrencer l'avion il est deux
fois plus rapide
d'autre part il fait appel à une
technologie éprouvée
électrique à 100% contrairement aux tgf
qu'on doit présenter et un en grande
partie électrifié mais également au
diesel donc aimé par de gs encore une
fois le projet de tgf tiennent toutefois
la route pour la mairesse de montréal
il faut qu'on puisse comme société se
donner des moyens transport rapide
efficace entre les grandes métropoles
c'est c'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir
soutenir tout l'écosystème économique et
revenir sur la planche à dessin n'est
pas la chose à faire quand le porte
parole en matière de transport du bloc
québécois
ça veut dire que si on décide d'arrêter
le tgf les consultations sur le trajet
du projet sont prévues cet automne
auprès notamment de 36 communauté
autochtone ici daniel kadjo radio canada
montréal